this is it folks the week that will go
down as possibly
the biggest week of xbox's history we're
going to be talking about
that bethesda acquisition and what it
means as well as how their pre-orders
went
upgrades from current to next-gen titles
and the huge huge fact
that the xbox series x is currently out
in the wild
joining me to break down the news from
this historic week
i've got xbox series expert jordan
remain
what's up xbox series expert tamar
hussein
absolutely lubricated for these consoles
lads
and we're also joined by a very special
guest
merry christmas xbox it's usher not that
special guest
we'll try again later
this has been one of the biggest news
weeks that i can remember
uh kicked off monday morning with the
news that uh microsoft had acquired
bethesda
we did uh we all banded together did a
really in-depth breakdown of the news
uh on the channel you can go watch it
right now we'll link it below and maybe
even
a little clip here i don't know evan
that's up to you
but uh let's talk a little bit about
some more of the tidbits that have been
rolling out throughout the week uh
jordan i'm gonna come to you first
let's talk exclusives and studios
obviously the stable for xbox has now
just like
they've almost doubled how many studios
that are in their first party lineup
how about to say and if you look at like
how many studios they had going
into the xbox one console generation
it's closer to like
tripling like from seven years ago or
something like that
it's massive i remember thinking like
man xbox is going to have
so many studios like actually more than
sony and playstation going into the xbox
series x and s that's really impressive
it's something i never thought it was
going to happen
like four or five years ago and then
just all of a sudden like
on the eve of the console coming out
they're like oh yeah and here's just
eight more also coming so we have over
20 studios now
making first party most likely console
exclusives
for xbox and assuming that each studio
makes at least
one game for this console generation
that's 20 first party console exclusives
and that's
that's impressive that's a lot of new
games coming to xbox
well we don't know like exactly how the
console exclusivity will work
i i'm kind of in the camp that they're
not gonna lock everything off
to xbox just like they did with
minecraft you know minecraft is still
playable on
like everything at this point so but in
terms
of things that are gonna be coming to
game pass day one
that's a huge huge boon for them uh tam
what do you think about the
the ps5 stuff that we know is in
production as currently as a console
exclusive
um what does that what does this
acquisition mean for ps5
and exclusives going forward so the game
specifically that we're talking about as
it relates to bethesda are
ghostwire tokyo and death loop arcane
and um tango so those games
phil spencer has said they're gonna
continue to honor the agreements around
those and the agreement being they are
console exclusive that's an important
kind of caveat to this at all because
microsoft isn't completely cut out of
any sort of involvement with those games
they are pc
available as well and obviously that
means that people who are playing on pc
are working within microsoft's ecosystem
so phil spencer has committed to that
for now and then everything else going
forward is going to be on a case-by-case
basis which
kind of lends credence to what lucy was
saying about um
you know not everything being locked
behind a
a xbox wall um it's in their interest to
you know make sure that there's
availability across platforms to them so
we'll see how that shakes out
the other thing is like when exclusivity
deals console exclusively deals aren't
usually in perpetuity it's not always
like for the lifetime of
you know the the existence of video
games so there's a good chance that
there's a timed window in which is
exclusive we've seen that happen with
many many many games over the long
history of exclusivity and video games
as a whole
so it could be that three years into the
cycle two years maybe even a year
um death loop and goals by tokyo become
available on xbox consoles instead of
just pc
so as it stands they're gonna honor the
agreement
but i think personally that there's a
timer on that agreement we just don't
know about it yet
and then going forward i expect that
microsoft fail sponsors and the various
other teams
involved in that will be thinking about
what benefits them and game pass the
most how can they take a game
that is available on multiple consoles
and inject it with additional value that
people can only get through game pass
game plus gives them a lot of value as
is but
is there anything they can do more to it
that will um
attract people towards game pass but
game pass
as of something that's valuable like if
uh
you watch the interview uh we've got
major nelson
phil sponsors uh pete hines and todd
howard
and if you're anything like me you spend
ages just like looking at the background
of everyone's shots to see if anyone's
teasing anything
but todd is actually talking about how
you know like the relationship with
microsoft has been over the years but he
he specifically calls out how great game
pass is and that it's some it's a
service that he's been looking for
for years and now it's finally in this
incredible
stage where you know just stuff is
getting added to it day one and it's a
fantastic service and so that definitely
you know when you're thinking about the
acquisition you definitely want bethesda
to be on board with having their titles
available day one
but jordan i'm gonna come to you because
like game pass is just this behemoth now
we call it the best deal in gaming and
it just
keeps proving time and time again that
it is but
what benefits is it gonna have going
forward into this next generation now
that bethesda are on board
it's one of those like huge things that
i don't think we're going to
see the true ramifications of it until
like
five maybe 10 years down the line but
it's one of those things that i
think about where xbox has made all of
these moves over the past
two years that tie into game pass where
theoretically you could now get the xbox
series s
for 25 a month with all access which
includes game pass ultimate which now
includes
all these new bethesda games like
dishonored 2
fallout star field and elder scroll 6
whenever they
come out and how that's going to change
the way that people from like low-income
households or
just people who just normally can't get
the new console at launch and can't get
these amazing games like maybe they only
get one or two games a year so they've
just missed out on dishonored two and
they've just missed out on
skyrim and now they get the chance to
play these games day one
when they come out and how so many game
developers and journalists
get into the roles that they do because
they played that one game that one
special game that they
fell in love with and that inspired them
to pursue
some sort of career and how now there's
just going to be this huge like part of
the community
that has never been able to play new
games before now
now has the chance to do so and bethesda
is one of the biggest
names in gaming and xbox is like oh yeah
star field day one for free
on xbox game pass with a subscription
and how that's just
a huge step in forms of affordability
if you include like accessibility in
that like a bunch of
people don't necessarily know what sort
of accessibility options the game is
going to have game pass now allows them
to try that game now for
quote unquote free before maybe like oh
i can't actually play this game and
they're
not losing money out on it and xbox is
just quietly making these
moves and that are just going to have
these huge ramifications i think on our
industry like
years from now like they won't be
immediately apparent but
it'll be amazing to see if this attracts
just a bunch of new voices that we've
never had a chance to get into the
industry before and they're moves that
just sony and nintendo just aren't
making and xbox is like
we're going to be the forerunners in
this we're going to take the first step
it's interesting you keep mentioning
starfield there because obviously that
is such a huge draw despite the fact
that
no one knows anything about it and if
you've got if you've got time please
watch that interview with bethesda and
microsoft because
there's a moment in that interview where
major nelson just like
zooms in on todd how and he's like
what's up with starfield
and todd just basically says nothing
it's fantastic which is uh which was
nice segue to my next question because
i'm since i'm controlling everything
here
starfield what's up
anyway uh before we move on from this
acquisition
they've also opened up the like
microsoft aren't
done which is a really exciting uh
possibility
time do you want to read the quote from
phil talking to sister website
cena yeah so i'll come to phil first but
also it's worth uh
i'll come to phil in a second but it's
also worth getting the perspective of
the
the boss ceo of microsoft satya nadella
who also spoke to cnet
um and he said that we'll always look
for places where there are
where there is that commonality of
purpose mission and culture
we always look to grow where it makes
sense so this is kind of couched in the
understanding that
more game studio purchases could happen
in the future
and then speaking to cena again um phil
said that content is just the incredible
ingredient
to our platform that we continue to
invest in this doubles the size of our
creative
organization so there are definitely
opportunities going forward for xbox to
acquire even more studios
i mean i think it will be a little while
before that happens but the important
thing is like this is all
to give further value to one game pass
because
as it stands game pass doesn't make a
lot of money if i
all i believe that it doesn't make them
a profit right now
but they are currently investing in the
future there's going to be opportunities
for them to monetize game pass in a way
that
they're not perhaps being as aggressive
with it'll be interesting to see whether
they start doing things like making
dlc expansions the game fully paid
instead of making them more available on
game pass because
you get a base game for free if you want
more of it you gotta cough up the money
for it or even like micro transactions
again like
you know skyrim or oblivion you want to
buy that horse armor you still gotta
spend
different you know a separate cash
amount to get it
but yeah there's definitely um huge
opportunities for them to grow
going forward who knows what they could
buy um
i think they're very smart in what they
purchase but there's a lot of potential
there
um i definitely want to hear what our
special guest
has to say about this happy new year
xbox
hoping you're having a wonderful 2013.
turns out not much of value
no no evan can you soy
please another huge moment for xbox
this week uh one that maybe didn't go
down as well as i think we were all
hoping after
uh ps5 last week but that pre-orders
went live
how did yours go we didn't film this one
because i was in bed and
i have a rule of no cameras before 8 30.
it's a good rule i was like a troll
like my hair was everywhere jordan how
did your pre-order experience go
i say unlike playstation 5 i did
actually manage to get
an xbox so i'm happy i'm
getting it day one i will have at least
one next-gen
console going into this next console
generation
tom how long did it take you uh mine was
uh
as you know i'm weirdly lucky with stuff
like this so
mine was super painless the luckiest man
alive
unbelievable how quickly you get
tickets to things like when hamilton
came to the uk
tam got us uh tickets for i think the
second or third ever showing
yeah like an incredible i like typed in
the url for the ticket website and it
was like you were number one in the
queue i was like cool
i'll just get there and then like harry
potter and the cursed child came
came out and everyone was trying to get
it and i was like huh i wonder if i can
get any tickets and i clicked the link
and it was like you are number one in
the queue i was like
how oh they're like i i really touch
i rolled up to the playstation to the
xbox pre-orders and i was like i'm gonna
try it on the xbox website a refresher
and it was like had to call
i was like yep that'll do and then like
um i saw that amazon went live
it's like uh let me try on amazon and if
it works i'll cancel the other one i
went to amazon hit the load button it
gave me a dog i was like oh it's a dog
and then i hit it again and it was like
i took a car and i was like yep that'll
do so i had i
struggled way more with xbox and i did
playstation like playstation i was just
on walmart refreshing for a bit and then
i eventually got it i got in straight
away on amazon
uh xbox was strange because
uk seemed to go painlessly um pretty
much
um i think our friend uh simon carty was
saying that you know that
the s hadn't even sold out in the uk us
i lucked out with the microsoft store
that seemed to be the most reliable it
was very very slow
amazon not going live at eight was
very very strange and very frustrating
and it was kind of like the same thing
and
this is you know putting into sony
putting it to microsoft putting it even
to nintendo for when the switch launched
it's like
we need to have a better way of doing of
dealing with pre-orders i get that these
are unprecedented times everyone is at
home and online
having having a date and time is really
great but there needs to be some kind of
forethought
to think of demand like you must have
assumed that people would
be overloading those stores to try and
get them and
so that's a general criticism at
everyone i get that it's unprecedented
times but
you could also see the frustration in a
lot of people when they just couldn't
get the console that they wanted but
hopefully wave two and wave three will
be
much much smoother so it's also
important to know like a lot of times
this
isn't the platform holder's fault like
in sony's case it wasn't
really their fault retailers
it was that absolutely spicy walmart um
behavior and the same for microsoft
microsoft uh in terms of how they
approached the rollout was a little
cleaner
they gave everyone a time and they most
nothing went live before then if you
unless you were in new zealand or
uk and the territory mad but it was the
retailers that really took a hammering
so
the important thing to realize is when
in these situations when you are
complaining on twitter don't aim it at
the platform holder because they did
their job was to try and make sure that
people got a certain mark
if the amazon servers fall over or you
know
various other walmart target servers
have an issue that's not really there
for microsoft store maybe
but like demand was the big issue there
um and they could definitely have scaled
better for their own
kind of um store which but generally
it's the retailer issue not microsoft's
only on nintendo so
but also don't don't attack like retail
workers yeah let's say you're going to
lose us that sweet sweet walmart
sponsorship
we have a walmart function we don't have
a walmart sponsorship
although hang on so they did delete this
but um
you know how ios 14 update in they added
widgets
i think no no target
uh i think it was target or another
retailer tweeted don't mind us just
spent the last hour making our phone
screen
really aesthetic and every single
response was stuck more ps5 stuck my ps4
stuff on my xbox
and they deleted the tweet like it was
uh it was just a
that poor community manager one day just
rolling up uh
yeah just thinking i'll make a fun
zeitgeisty meme about
ios 14 widgets and uh the gamers kicking
in the doors
like i just any time anytime a brand
does a tweet on twitter i imagine gamers
like entering a room like
kazuma kiryu kicking that door in and
walking in and being like
the gamers are here there you go evan
there's your excuse to get our
beloved boy in well speaking of our
beloved boy we do
have an important update from our very
special guest
happy easter xbox no come on evan
sort this out uh but you know this is
the the final
point of xbox's big big week is the fact
that
damn the xbox series x is out in the
wild and it's not just a cardboard
version that we made ourselves to try
and figure out how big it would be
it's not the dummy model that they sent
out a couple weeks ago
uh so you could get a feel for how big
everything was this is a fully
working xbox series x almost two four
months out
from the release of the console itself i
don't remember this happening like
getting access to consoles at least
i guess you know we're not in the office
but like at home
i remember when the xbox one came out
like they were like in london they made
a little apartment and you could go book
appointments and go play on the console
but you couldn't have one at home
uh very excited to have xboxes out in
the wild and so to celebrate
we've got a very special message from
our textbook michael hyam
who's going to be joining us to talk
about it next week happy easter xbox
[Music]
hey everyone michael here editor at
gamespot and i have
the xbox series x the fully functioning
real console
now i'm going to be heading up our
hands-on impressions previews technical
breakdowns
all that good stuff on gamespot now i
need to get to work though but that's
all i can share for now so stay tuned
we got there eventually evan thank you
we have that pre-recorded message from
michael he will be
on generation next next week so if you
have questions about the xbox series x
what it's like to have in your home
please leave them in the comments below
um or come at one of us on twitter and
we'll put them to michael
next week uh guys how are you feeling
about the fact that the series x is
is out there i i think it's such a smart
move and
this show isn't about pitting one
against the other which is you know
we've both got pre we've
got pre-orders for both of these but i
will say it's interesting that sony's
strategy has been to
keep the console very close to their
chest right now the feeds
the social feeds the youtube feeds the
twitter feeds the high five myspace
uh bibo habbo hotel um adult friend
finder feeds are all just full of
xbox xbox xbox and it seems like a very
carefully thought out flooding the
systems kind of strategy and meanwhile
sony has very
little kind of to to push back against
it
it's almost being drowned out in the
kind of public conversation so
it's only if you're watching get to it
maybe send out some
ps5s to some people and i'll send you my
address
i'll send you my address if you want to
send one here
please send us consoles send anyone
consoles so we can learn anything about
it um but yeah it's super exciting to
have it out there in the world
jordan i'm jealous that i can't touch
one but it
probably makes a lot more sense for
national treasure michael hyam to have
it since he actually knows what he's
talking about when he uses words like
teraflops i would just like hold and be
like
damn this looks so pretty and it plays
all the games that i love and that's all
i'd be able to say about it
michael hyam is known for getting up all
in in them guts so
he's gonna do it again he'd love to see
it and i think that's what we're gonna
call a show for today
uh all right like i said questions about
the series x
from someone who's actually been playing
it comments below
tam where can people find you you can
find me getting up all in them guts on
twitter at tomorrow h
jordan find me on twitter at jmremay
oh hang on wait wait biggest news from
that interview
is that um pete hines said bill uh big
phil fan
you know what sorry i muted because my
dogs went nuts um
they're big phil fins they're big fill
fins they're big phil fans hi my name is
phil
uh most of my friends call me big phil
big phil fan
big fail i used our nickname for phil
it's canon it's canon now uh
all right i'm on twitter at lucy james
games and we'll see you next week
you